good morning I'm Michelle Miller and
we're in the CBS this morning Toyota
green moon to discuss one of the most
famous films to never be released that
is until now
amazing grace captures Aretha Franklin
recording her legendary gospel album of
the same name over the course of two
days in 1972 producer Alan Elliott along
with Franklin's niece Sabrina Owens and
nephew Vaughn Franklin are here to talk
about the documentary that took 46 years
to make it to the big screen welcome
thank you good morning thank you for
having us oh my goodness why did it take
this long we're talking Aretha Franklin
here that's how long it took come on the
back story behind it we don't have
enough time for the back story yes we
they mess up the technical aspects of it
46 years ago and that was a funky way to
elongate everyone's life it was a
synchronicity problem usually you know
the clapper everyone is so it's so
famous in the moviemaking business
Sydney [ __ ] who it sort of brought
these these features together and wanted
to make this talk about why Aretha
miss Franklin wanted to to film it in
South Central Los Angeles in the venue
that she did okay
well Reverend James Cleveland had his
choir and his church in Los Angeles and
he was the most famous figure in modern
gospel at the time and Aretha was doing
an episode of room 222 I remember that
[ __ ] okay and so they came out to Los
Angeles they brought the band from
Atlantic Records and it's January so
everybody wanted to go to Los Angeles
from New York it's so cold in New York
so they came to Los Angeles to they
thought that do they do rehearsals they
would do the show room 222 and then they
would go and film the movie and that's
where the adventure starts to fall down
so this adventure Sabrina take us
through how watch
what has now come to scream take us
through the process of what we see so
basically I didn't become involved in
this until really after my aunt passed
but the first I heard of the film was
about three years ago when I get a call
from Alan and he actually sends me a
link to the film and I look at it and I
absolutely love it
and so we didn't know at that point when
it would make it to the screen or not
and then after my aunt passed Alan came
to Detroit about four six weeks later
and previewed it for my family and
friends and everybody loved let's be
really clear here miss Franklin really
didn't want this to make it to the big
screen why why wouldn't she want this to
happen we really don't know the details
behind all of that but I look at it as
timing maybe the time wasn't right back
then but now we felt that as a family
along with Alan that time was right now
so I think is all around timing set the
stage for us here she is but I'll tell
you why okay okay this is my belief so
you have to come up with these theories
first of all I was seven years old when
they made the movie so we're dealing
with the seven year olds intellect at
this point still and inside that she's
the most famous woman in the Warner
Music Group right she's has 13 number
one records in a row and the film
company drops the ball and she wanted to
be a movie star this is her this is her
apex she's made amazing grace which is
her best-selling album and the record
company gets everything together but the
film company does not and I'm sure for
someone as competitive and as you know
as dedicated as Aretha was I know her
Purdue you know my mentor was her
producer Jerry Wexler and he was a to me
the record company we did our job the
film company didn't and I can only
imagine what that is on a long level of
a missed opportunity for her that she
would have been mad about and then
trying to figure out the Methos that
goes on because there's a lot of cya
what would that be covering your okay so
in a corporate world why didn't the
movie get made well there was a problem
well whose fault was it what was this
one's fault no is that one's fault no
and you now you're dealing with Aretha
Franklin Sydney [ __ ] Warner Brothers
films Warner Brothers Records Atlantic
Records there's a lot of cya that has to
go into that and in that it becomes this
what are you gonna say what why didn't
things happen because they didn't happen
because they didn't do this they had
done that there would have been a movie
there would have been a movie yeah I I
want you to take me so you saw you were
too big screening last night uh one of
my friends was there he loved it I saw
your friend
you saw my yeah I did you did not but
this was really just her in the church
singing her heart out and that was a
special part about it that it was just
sir there was no flash no bang no
electronic equipment it was just my aunt
standing there doing what she does best
singing gospel and it just touched her
soul she's singing sweats pouring down
her face she's putting her whole heart
and soul into this it was very authentic
very pure you saw a side of her that you
don't normally see on the regular stage
there was a shyness about her at some
points and then there was a confidence
about her at other points like when she
was sashay down the aisle you see the
confidence just reeking from her and
then when she gets on the stage there's
a deference probably like you see with a
lot of people in a church atmosphere but
she was just singing and it was just
very touching very inspiring she was at
home she was I think she was at home and
in her element cuz she grew up in the
church so when she got she was up on
stage and singing in front of the
audience yet the gospel music going
behind her just like Sabrina said you
saw a shyness but yet you saw a certain
level of confidence and then when our
grandfather was there when Reverend CL
Franklin walked in I think that jazz was
a relationship that they had was very
special it was very evident on
you know it was like a mutual admiration
society she admired her dad he loved her
as he said my daughter it would how
would he put it she you know she was
just a stone singer as he put it and I
think you saw her revert back to a
certain level of her childhood because
when he walked in she saw it she saw him
I think she humbled herself even more so
then because father's in the room you
know my dad is someone I admire look
right and the one that has been my
backbone throughout my entire career
he's in the room now yes so I think that
was a great moment in a movie this
wasn't a huge venue no church I think
about Miss Franklin I had the pleasure
of meeting her a few times but I
presented her it was in Times Square and
going backstage the woman who was very
sweet shot everyone was like okay well I
went in there and she was lovely then
yes she she took me by the shoulder and
she led me on to stage and said go ahead
on out there now you know you can tell
when her performance was over by whether
that person or not yes oh my gosh so I
would imagine you said that connect yes
with you've seen this film more than
once yes I have and we were talking
about how you pick up something new each
time right
what was your pick up on I saw my aunt
Carolyn last night for the person I
don't know I should have seen it the
very first time but this is about my
fourth and fifth time and I actually I'm
looking and was like oh my god there's
my aunt Carolyn jumping up yes I told
you and then I saw her more than once
why didn't I see that before yeah what
about you Vaughn there was nothing new I
guess I miss her and whenever I see on
screen I'm just focused on her because
it brings back a lot of memories so the
things going on around her that wasn't
when I was focused on I'm sure if I go
back and watch a later on then I see the
things that Sabrina saw but it's just me
seeing her up on stage wife initially
you are focused on her the very first
maybe the first second third time right
the focus was on her her music how it
made me feel and then after that I
started seeing other things around her I
started noticing just the fashions and
you know the lady in the fly pad and
things like that but it takes a few
times to get past the focus of her yeah
so it has been several months since your
aren't passed away a beautiful ceremony
what an amazing tribute to her the
memorial service was what would she say
what do you think she would say about
this now I think she would be very
excited and very proud of that moment
because Detroit in the world showed up
and showed out and it was done at such a
high level and we had the help of as we
call the rethus angels that helped to
execute that whole program and I think
because it was done so well and
everything for her had to be done at the
highest levels that I think she would
have been very pleased and look who's
joined us Terrell Whitley one of the
other producers so glad of you to join
us absolutely it's magic but I would ask
you as well what do you think that miss
Franklin would say about what you have
been able to produce year after 46 years
of pushing aside waiting maybe it's
coming no I don't want it what would she
say now you're a pig well that's a big
question I think and I'm course we're
here with the Franklin family and so I
really have to get my answer kind of
pulled from what I've gathered from our
conversations of what we've discussed
and I would believe that miss Franklin
would appreciate our approach and the
fact that we have taken the highest
level of respect and honoring her legacy
that we're working directly with lon and
with Sabrina and a way to ensure that
the project goes forward and it
highlights the great things about her
legacy is there something to be said
about it coming out
this is a ball there is grace yeah what
are is something to be said I mean right
now we're in interesting times and our
world you know as much as a wreath I was
saying this to someone this more as much
as the wreath it was a great performer
great singer she's also an activist and
her message and the way that she carried
out her message and how she used her
gift was to help change the world and to
bring people together and I think we've
taken that approach we're talking to
Flint in the water crisis we're looking
at what's happening in California with
the wildfires we're talking about voter
suppression so we're trying to be
conscious and appropriate to what her
calling was as a harness as a singer as
the Queen of Soul but then also as an
activist and I think a lot of that comes
from our conversations with the Franklin
family because she in the 1960s and 70s
not only initiated get-out-the-vote
campaigns but helped to fund many other
civil rights moves along the way now
here's what's interesting
46 years later we're still having a lot
of the same conversations so she's as
relevant today as she was there yes she
is this has a limited release this year
talk to us if you will about when it
comes out here in New York and Los
Angeles we we wanted to do a mic drop
which was no nobody we huddled with each
other after we showed the movies six
weeks ago how do we sort of go in and
and take over the Oscars how do we go
and take awards season how do we have
the biggest bang on this with nobody
knowing about it because we didn't want
to have we own the movie this is our
movie and it's important for us because
last night Reverend barber came and did
a speech afterwards Reverend Al Sharpton
came and did the invocation before for
us to do to help out with the clean
water from Flint campaign for us to work
with Reverend Barbara on the Poor
People's Campaign are really important
legacy things that we feel is true to
Aretha but to your point of where is it
going to be when is it going to be so we
didn't tell anybody that we qualified
for the Oscars we had to do that by
October first we made that deadline by
26 minutes
we did it without a publicist we did it
pretty much without a lawyer we didn't
tell anybody we were doing it except the
families here and we became a family in
that sort of way and the idea was of
course you have to do oscar qualifying
so you have to do a week run in Los
Angeles which is November 20th through
the 27th and in New York the 7th through
the 14th of December at film forum and
and this is really a vehicle for her
causes yes absolutely I think that
should be said it is really a vehicle
for her causes yeah and what would we
tell what is she telling us today don't
mess it up I know she is we are gonna
wrap it up we wish you the best of luck
our sympathy still with thank you and
the family and all that really you know
cared for this amazing amazing amazing
grace that she was to all of us I want
to say thank you Alan Elliott I want to
say thank you to Elle Whitley I want to
say thank you Sabrina
Owen and Vaughn Frankish airing this all
on Facebook thank you